Dan Attias, Director, Producer and Author:He had
originally played it really oppositionally “Then
I’m a rat!” You know angry at him and I said
"You know since we’re dramatizing a transition
I think it’d be much better if you realize you
can’t communicate to this guy."Film Courage:
Can you tell us some of the challenges
you faced directing the second episode of
The Sopranos?Dan:The Sopranos was interesting.
I had met David Chase when he was a showrunner
onNorthern Exposurewhich was a wonderful show
in the mid 90’s, which I really recommend people
seek out. David then went on to direct the pilot
forThe Sopranosand there were several months
before HBO decided to make it as a series and
I was very honored and happy that David called
me to direct the first episode that would air
following the pilot. The company came together
I think six or nine months after the original
pilot had been shot. When I saw the pilot I just
saidOh my God! This is the greatest thing I’ve
ever seen.There were challenges. It was almost
like shooting a pilot again because it was a whole
new company coming together and it was the first
episode. James Gandolfini for example who had made
a wonderful career as a kind of part-time player
in a lot of different shows was not used to a
television schedule. I remember the first scene we
shot, he was ready to call it a day and we saidNo
James, we’ve got four more scenes today.But
one of the interesting things in that episode (it
was called46 Long)and I directed other episodes
of The Sopranos. That may be my favorite one if
you haven’t seen it, I really recommend it. But
among some of the more memorable moments
in it was the episode actually about
Tony having to commit his mother played by Nancy
Marchand to an assisted living facility and one
thing i'll share that David Chase has spoken
about is that and what really informed the series
and gave it a lot of real great inner life is that
David had a mother that was the model for Olivia a
real kind of sociopathic misanthropic human being
that was very challenging for him just as you see
Nancy Marchand's behavior is so challenging for
Tony Soprano and in this episode he's trying to
convince her to go into green grove retirement
community and one of the things that finally
convinces him that he has to force her to is that
there's a there's a very funny scene in the in the
episode where she's dropping her friend off at
home and she drives this big green honker of a
car up a steep driveway and the friend just gets
out and get leans down to pick up the newspaper
and nancy marshall looks behind her thinks she's
backing out but then presses the accelerator
and runs into the into the friend who falls right
back into the windshield and it was it was one of
those moments fortunately the stunt person was all
right but it was one of those moments that it just
sometimes it happens that fade is with you and the
elements just come together was a beautiful fun
stunt but one of the challenges I had and I cite
this in the book because I have a chapter entitled
creating the world of your story which is another
way of saying creating contextualizing things
because context contextualizing is so important
to bring the audience along to acquaint them
with what are the conditions that they're being
acquainted with it permits them to understand
what's happening if you don't do that work
your things can happen and they don't land
because people don't understand in what context
they're happening or what's what's going on so
that part of much of the job of directing for
me is to is to kind of fill in things for an
audience of you know as as unobtrusively as as
you know without calling attention to it I'm
acquainting them with the rules of this world
and and the situ the specifics of the situation
and in the pilot many people I'm sure will recall
you know Tony was revealed as suffering from panic
attacks and he had he had sought out lorraine
bronco playing dr melfi as help and that was
one of the genius conceits of the whole show
that mob boss having talk therapy so in this
episode there was one sequence where I want to
talk about it just because it was an example of
finding a way to contextualize something to
give the audience a deeper experience of it
and there was a an early sequence when
Tony is approached at his place of work
he goes into work and he's having to
juggle many things he's having to juggle
trying to reach a important business partner and
his assist his guy who's answering the phone being
totally inept and cutting him off and him worried
about that he's having to adjust with various
people coming up to him silvio and christopher
and with their own their own needs and saying to
tone we've got to do this and they're all they're
trying to please him but they all feel entitled
to his attention so that was one of the
things I wanted to do I wanted to create
the sense of the stress Tony lived with so I
would direct all so one of the things I did was
to direct all the actors to make sure when they
approached Tony that they felt completely entitled
to take all of his time to hear the particulars
their intention being to impress their boss
but they're not aware that comedically they're
actually pissing him off a lot because they're
not allowing him to get to the 12 other things
he has to do so that was kind of happening and
he also is having to find the his wife carmella
has asked him to help help out junior's
junior high school teacher who had his
saturn car stolen can't we try to find it
so he's having to please carmela he's having to
please this business associate he's having to
address all of his you know you know all of his
underlings needs and he's you can see he's just
tightly wound but he's doing a really great job
of it and until he gets a call from his mother
and that's the show-stopping centerpiece of the
sequence when you get to see the dynamic and the
between olivia and Tony all right so I wanted to
create a context for understanding that the first
gambit was of course to give everybody this
kind of entitlement as they approach him and
not responding to any of his cues that he has
anything else to think about but with olivia I
wanted to kind of somehow create in the audience
an awareness of how difficult a personality she
was for him and I thought you know this is a strip
club this is the bada bing as everybody knows
most people and and there were these new dancers
on the dance floor you know doing the pole dancing
and I thought it would be really interesting
if I when Tony takes the call from his mother
if I position him in such a way that these new
dancers are dancing behind his head and that
also affected my lens choices because you know to
shoot say a shot this size on a person a close-up
you can do it with a long lens which means you see
very little of the background behind because it's
telephoto or you can bring the camera in really
close and have a wide lens which means you see
you know the whole room so I chose a wide lens to
shoot Tony you know answering this call from his
mother who you know misses no opportunity
to guilt-trip him about his inattention
and while he's talking to her and she's being very
very difficult these nude women are dancing behind
his head and I don't know that anybody would have
made this connection but I think subliminally
you make the connection that when he's talking
to this woman who invokes these kind of
primal feminine forces that are so difficult for
him I thought having these new dancers behind
his head as he's talking to his mother would
somehow humanize Tony and like it would it would
you know make him the child again and against you
know with these these feminine figures powerful
feminine figures kind of dancing in his head that
he's powerless to defend against so that was how
I filmed it and I thought that you know and then
the scene was great I mean olivia winds up setting
fire to her kitchen and Tony doesn't know what
to do he says stop everything he's doing and run
you know get carmela to go over to the house so
it's kicked off the episode in an interesting way
but I thought it was by contextualizing the
moment in a subtle way that wasn't scripted
it was a way you know it's a it's a touch that
a director has opportunity to bring if you can
think of it that way you know there was another
instance of that i'll cite and another great show
I was fortunate to direct the wire I directed
several of several seasons of the wire and I
directed an episode in four of the five seasons
and in the last season I directed an episode
called transitions and one and that showed
various characters transitioning to different
levels of responsibility or within the
hierarchy either of the drug culture or the
police department and you know several climatic
thing hap things happened one of which was prop
joe one of the beloved characters beloved he was
a tough drug dealer but he was a great character
he's executed in this episode by the character
marlow so you see him transitioning to the end
of his life while marlow transitions to ascend to
the top of the drug hierarchy there are various
transitions like that happening throughout and
one of them was between two characters who were
kind of comedic relief a lot of the time but also
genuine characters in their arm right to police
carver and herc and herc the previous
season they'd gotten and they'd had
a lot of misadventures together we'd
seen over various seasons and finally
herc had been drummed out of the force
for some indiscretion he had done
carver in this season has been promoted to become
a sergeant so he's having to see things from the
other side of the desk in a little different way
and what happens in the episode is that um he
he sees that he has more responsibility and that
he can no longer look the other way and one of his
one of the police guys working beneath him has
done something very bad he's actually attacked
a school teacher in the midst of a routine drug
bust and he's been cited by the department and
the police his own troops are gathering around
him okay this is how we're going to do it you
know we'll tell him you know the guy was being
obstructionist which we know he wasn't he was a
simple bystander and carver confronts the
character as colicchio as a character for
those of fans of the wire and he tells kaliko
he's trying to help him and he says okay
this is what we're going to do we're going to
say this happened this happened this happened
this happened and collected says nah [ __ ] him
he was an [ __ ] and I'm glad I did what I did
and carver just looks at them and just
says okay you're toast I'm turning you in
and Collectio says then you are a rat
and garbage just says then I'm a rat
and i'll say this this wasn't the point I
was going to get to get to another point but
that was fun it was a fun moment for me because I
realized I helped the actor with carver with that
line because he had originally played it really
oppositionally then I'm a rat you know angry at
him and I said you know since we're dramatizing
a transition I think it'd be much better if you
realize you can't communicate to this guy with
this guy you're not you see in his refusal to
take responsibility that you he's lost you so let
him think whatever he wants don't oppose him like
to change his view and he just threw it away says
then I'm a rat knowing I'm not a rat you're an
and and so that was kind of a nice moment but the
point I was trying to get to was that there was a
scene where the other police officers try to get
carver to reconsider not to turn in kalikio so
they enlist the help of his former former partner
herc who's no longer in the force and they get
herc to meet with him in the parking lot of the
precinct to say try to talk some sense in him
come on appeal come on we're brothers here don't
don't do this so there's a scene where the two of
them are having a beer in the precinct parking
lot and again trying to contextualize I put I
put a symbol of Herc's new he's he's now signed on
with a corrupt lawyer and he's gone for the money
and he's driving a Mercedes so I put a Mercedes
right there and so carver is sitting on the hood
of a police car with with Herc on the police
car but you can see the the Mercedes so you get
a sense of okay this is how things have changed
and in the course of the discussion what's going
to happen is Herc is going to say come on come
on what do you think maybe cut him some slack
you know is it really so bad and carver doesn't
answer him directly instead he spends a story
which we've seen in in a previous season Herc had
had missed his head had not acted on something he
he needed to act on in order to save one of the
most endearing characters a young boy named randy
who had snitched and helped the police in a way he
should have because it was a horrific thing that
he witnessed but he made it very clear you can't
tell anyone that this has happened or I'm i'm dead
and he they set up a set of signals that
would happen if it looks like he's about to be
outed and the police were going to correct
you know somehow create a different impression
and herc missed the signal so the boy randy
wound up getting labeled as a snitch and he
wasn't killed but he was sent to a reform school
where he was beaten every day and he was totally
deadened as a character and carver knows this
and instead of answering kirk directly he says
you know randy you know that character randy
and herc says yeah so what he says well you know
we let him down you let him down he said yeah
so what he says well it matters is what it all
matters so you get that sense that in this
moment you're watching a transition happen
that hurt that that carver has now accepted
that there are consequences to the way we act
and the force of how he did it simply shows
Herc that he's right and Herc instead of
transforming carver is himself transformed and
he says you do what you have to do turn Koikyo in
it's the right thing to do don't don't don't
don't care at all what the other guys think
about it's the right thing to do okay so that's
the transition that's what we're dramatizing
and it's a powerful scene and it would have played
great and they did great but I was thinking what
can I do to contextualize this to give it perhaps
greater depth and resonance and I and during prep
I remembered a previous episode of the wire and
one of the great things about the wire and the
storytelling and the wire David Simon and ed burns
David Simon created the show they never spoke down
to the audience and they never never felt they
had to recapitulate things you know in so many
stories if there's a story point that references
something from two seasons ago either they'll show
it previously on and they'll show that or they'll
have characters talk about reset it so that people
have it in their minds when they watch it here
the wire never did that if you missed something
in a season you missed it and then you know but
I had seen something in a previous season where
David Simon had scripted that when the police
exit into the precinct parking lot they're
drinking beer they ritually would hurl their beer
cans or bottles up onto the roof and the reason
he put that in is he had he had embedded
with the Baltimore homicide department
and he loved and this was a real thing they
did so he loved injecting these authentic
touches into the wire and I remembered this
scene where these guys apropos of nothing in
particular but they just had a beer or drank
and said hey and they threw it up on the roof
and I thought okay how might it be an interesting
thing to start the scene from the rooftop
and have a camera gliding across all these
discarded cans and bottles and seeing in the
frame down below Carver and Herc seated on the car
small figures and it would perhaps contextualize
what was happening here by create contextualize
this as a kind of ritual space this is a place
where policemen gather and let their hair down and
act and just you know speak truth to one another
and so that's what I did and I had in prep I asked
the prop department to go make sure you collect
tons of cans and bottles and all that and they
did it you know they were you know and we had a
special you know we had to get the camera up on
the roof and make sure it was safe and at a low
camera angle and I just just I didn't quite didn't
say anything about it but I just started the shot
going over these these discarded cans and
bottles so the hope was that the transition
that audiences would watch happening would have
a deeper significance because it would be as
if it's a transition within the culture itself
because we were in this ritualized space didn't
didn't cut back to it didn't do anything else but
it just set a context for those who really were
careful viewers of the show I think they'd
experience the scene a little more deeply.